as we descend from the heavens of
philosophical discussion of conservatism
and liberalism let's go to the pragmatic
muck of
politics Trump versus Biden between the
two of them who was in their first term
uh the better president and thus who
should win if the two of them are in
fact our choices should win a second
term in
20124 Ben sure so in terms of actual
performance you have to separate it into
a few categories uh in terms of actual
performance in foreign policy I think
Trump's foreign policy record is
significantly better than Biden's the
world being on fire right now being
fairly good example of that uh and we
can get into each aspect of the world
being on fire and where the incentive
structures came from and how all of that
happened in a moment when it comes to
the economy I think that Trump's
economic record was better than Biden's
doesn't mean he didn't overspend he did
he wildly overspent uh but he also had a
very solid record of job job creation a
huge percentage of the gains in the
economy went to people on the lower end
of the economic spectrum actually uh the
gross income to the average American
Rose about $6,000 during his term the
unemployment rates were very very low
before covid you I think that you almost
have to separate the Trump
Administration into sort of before Co
and during covid because Co obviously is
sort of a Black Swan event the the most
signal change in in politics in our
lifetime uh and so you know governance
during Co is almost its own category
which we can discuss um but you know in
terms of foreign policy in terms of
domestic policy I think that Trump was
significantly better than than Biden has
been and that's on the upside for Trump
on the downside for Biden obviously
you're talking 40e highs in inflation
you're talking about savings being eaten
away you're talking about everything
being 20 to 30 30% more expensive you're
talking about massive increases to the
deficit even at a rate that was unknown
under Trump the deficit under Trump
raised by about a little under a
trillion dollars every year up until
20120 again 2020 was Co year so
everybody decided that we're were going
to fire hose money at things um but uh
then Joe Biden continued to fire hose
money at things in 21 22 and 23 uh you
know that obviously is in my opinion bad
Economic Policy uh and then you get to
the rhetoric and you get to the stuff
that Donald Trump says and as I've said
before my view is that on Donald Trump's
half on his gravestone it will say
Donald Trump he said a lot of uh I
I think that Donald Trump does say a lot
of things I think that that is basically
baked into the cake which is why
everyone who's bewildered by the polls
is ignoring human nature which is at the
beginning when you see something very
shocking it's very shocking and then if
you see it over and over and over and
over for years on end it is no longer
shocking it is just part of the
background noise like tontis it just
becomes you know something that your
brain adjusts for uh and so do I like a
lot of Donald Trump's rhetoric no and I
never have do I think that that is just
positive as to his presidency no I do
not uh when it comes to Biden again I
think he's underperforming economically
I think that his foreign policy has been
really a a problem even the things I
think he's done right are I think
bandaids for things that he created by
doing wrong uh and when it comes to his
his own
rhetoric you can argue that it's grading
on a curve because Trump was coming in
with such wild rhetoric that just a
maintenance of that wild rhetoric
doesn't really change again the Baseline
for Biden he came in in the same way
that Obama did on the sort of soaring
rhetoric of American Unity I'm the
president for all like Trump came in
he's like listen I'm the president for
for what I am and you know I'm going to
say the things I want to say I'm be on
the toilet and I'm tweeting we're like
okay you know that's what it is with
Biden he came in with I'm a president
for all Americans I'm trying to unify
everybody and that pretty quickly broke
down into a lot of oppositional language
about his political opponents in
particular an attempt to lump in for
example huge swaths of the conservative
movement with the people who
participated for example in January 6th
or who are fans of January 6 um and um
you know the the the sort of lumping in
of everybody into Maga Republicans who
wasn't personally signed on to an
infrastructure bill with him that sort
of stuff I think has been truly terrible
I thought his Philadelphia speech was
truly terrible and again I think that
you do have the problem of he is no
longer capable of certainly rhetorically
unifying the country when every speech
from him feels like watching Nick Wenda
walk across a volcano on a tight RPP it
really is like you're just sort of
waiting for him to follow I mean it's
it's sad to say I mean the other day he
was speaking for what was in effect his
campaign kickoff and this is in Valley
Forge uh and I mean Jill rushed up there
like off the off the as soon as he was
done Jill rushed up there uh you know
like she'd been shot out of a cannon to
to come and try and guide him away so he
didn't become the Shane Gillis Roomba
and you know that that's not really you
know I let's put it this way it does not
quiet the soul to watch Joe Biden
rhetorically again that's a different
problem than Trump's problem but that
that's my
analysis uh this is one of the areas
where we get into this I don't
understand um if there's like brain
breaking happening or what's going on I
don't know what world we can ever live
in where we say that Trump is less
divisive for the country than Biden I
think it is so patently obvious Trump is
so divisive like not only does Trump
make an enemy out of every person in the
opposition party he makes an enemy out
of his own party and every single person
around him like we all watched him bully
uh you know Jeff sessions we all watched
him bully his own party on Twitter we
all watched like all of these people
walk away from him um even recently I
think um his uh the Secretary of Defense
esper and um John Kelly the chief of
staff were you know saying I think Trump
is a threat to democracy um you know
you've got all of his prior people that
were around him some of his closest
allies you've got Bill bar that won't
co-sign a single thing that he says um
you've got all these people that he used
to work with that all say Trump is a
horrible evil person he is ineffective
as a leader he doesn't accomplish
anything and he didn't you know to say
that Biden has failed at bipartisanship
when you know we've gotten the chips act
we've gotten the IRA we've gotten the uh
ARP we've gotten the bipartisan
infrastructure bill when we've got like
all this major legislation that is
working in this historically divided
Congress as opposed to Trump that got us
tax cuts and deficit spending um I I I
don't understand where we ever are in
this world where by is somehow more
divisive than Trump even the speeches
that Ben is bringing up I they always
bring up I remember that one um I think
we might have even done it on our
episode though the one speech that Biden
gave where at one point that like the
background is red andly speech reference
yeah like oh my God it's over this is
the end and then meanwhile you got
Donald Trump you know coming into office
saying things like if you burn the flag
you should have your citizenship revoked
or talking about Ms uh DNC that I'm
going to investigate every single one of
these uh media organizations for corrupt
I'm going to open the Lial and
defamation laws I'm going to take all of
these guys to court um you've got this
weird project 2025 stuff where um said
John pasal I think uh is talking about
uh you know we're going to we're going
to investigate all of these people and
we're going to try to throw crimes at
all these people uh Trump is like the
most divisive president I think we've
ever had in in at least in my lifetime
of being um an American citizen and the
retoric from him is just it's on a whole
other level in terms of the demonization
of political opponents I mean this is a
guy that's known for giving his
political opponents bad nicknames right
like that's what Trump does um you know
like it it's funny but even as a
resident of Florida if Florida had
another natural disaster do you think
Trump would withhold Aid because you had
uh I think that was one of the few nice
things that Des sandz actually said
about Biden was it like Hey listen you
know when the buildings collapsed in I
think that Miami Beach yeah that um you
know for the hurricane stuff that Biden
was there he was saying if you guys need
Aid however many billions you can have
it meanwhile Trump I think was
threatening to withhold Federal funding
from Blue states that wouldn't um I
think it had to do with the National
Guard stuff the deployment of the
National Guard that they weren't like
doing enough for the riots and and uh
Trump was threatening to withhold aid
from some of these blue States um yeah
Trump is literally the most divisive
person in the world I don't see how on
any metric he is ever succeeding in the
divisive category in terms of the
economy I do think it's funny that
Republicans are very keen to say that
like well we can't really grade Trump
you know postco because obviously Co
messed everything up which is fair but
pre-co what did Trump do yeah he did he
did deficit spending tax cuts he
presided over historic low interest
rates and an economy that was already
like like blazing past the final years
of Obama we were posting all-time highs
in all the stock markets from 2013
onwards um you know unemployment rates
were falling now under Biden
unemployment rates are even lower than
they were under Trump but uh it it sucks
that for Trump we can say well we can't
really hold him accountable over 2020
that was covid well all we have for
Biden is postco we don't have any pre-co
Biden uh you know economy and it was the
same thing for Obama too coming in right
after the housing collapse as well and
it sucks that Republicans are able to
walk out of office you know having
burned the entire American society to
the ground economically and now we've
got to try to evaluate okay well what
did Obama do during his first two to
three to four years just trying to
recover from where the housing crash
left it and then we look at Biden now
who's trying to recover from covid and
now we're grading him on on a totally
different scale than what Trump is being
graded on yeah that that sucks I think
comment on the foreign policy on the
foreign policy I'm going to be honest I
am a um I am very liberal I'm very not
Progressive uh I'll probably come off as
more hawkish than others uh because I'm
not a big fan of this which also if I
mean if Ben agrees like I think uh
people like people like Trump are going
to be the most doish isolationist people
ever they don't want to do anything uh
internationally they just want to you
know Protect America be at home protect
our economy don't do anything uh
internationally which is why he was
constantly undermining NATO uh and
constantly you know attacking all the
the European Union and you know cheering
on the UK for brexiting away from the EU
I think that being said um I think that
Biden has done a phenomenal job uh when
it comes to foreign policy I think that
the Coalition building was so important
for Ukraine Russia and I'm so happy that
he decided to go to our European allies
and our NATO allies and try to build a
coalition of people to help Ukraine so
that that wasn't only the United States
um personally especially after doing a
whole bunch of research I do tend to
side with Israel Over um Palestine and a
lot of the Israeli Palestinian conflicts
I'm glad that Biden while remaining a
staunch defender of Israel is trying to
re in some of the more aggressive
posturing towards uh the Palestinians in
the Gaza Strip I'm I'm proud that Biden
said Hey listen we are going to delay
some of these attacks Hey listen we are
going to allow humanitarian Aid here Hey
listen we are going to try to uh you
know not kill as many Palestinian people
down there while still you know
signaling that he would be a St
supporter of um of Israel in in the
conflict assuming the civilian
casualties don't go too high um for
foreign policy I mean blemishes I mean
like the the biggest one you can give to
Biden is Afghanistan and the poll out
there but man are we going to talk about
you know the uh Inspector General report
that says that one of the biggest
reasons why the Afghanistan pullet was
so disastrous was because of the Doha
Accords where Donald Trump headed talks
that didn't even include the Afghanistan
army uh I mean like these were disasters
like when when Biden took office we had
2500 troops left in Afghanistan like
what was the options even uh afforded to
Biden at that point um obviously you've
got the abandonment of the Kurds in
Northern Syria you know for the Turkish
armies to lay waste to um I talk about
Iran and North Korea although I'm not
sure where uh Ben would land on those
but yeah that's a broadly that's that's
a lot from both you want to pick pick us
something we you disagree with here well
I mean there's a lot so I mean so I want
to ask a few questions on each one of
these so let's let's talk about
divisiveness for a second so there's no
one who can make the case that Donald
Trump is not divisive of course he's
incredibly
divisive it's a given do you treat
Biden's rhetoric with the same level of
seriousness that you treat Trump's
rhetoric or I should probably put that
the other way around should we treat
Trump's rhetoric with the same level of
seriousness as Joe Biden or say Barack
Obama's rhetoric um I'm gonna try to be
concise when these broadly speaking
especially in studing Israel Palestine
and Ukraine Russia I try not to take
politicians at their word because
sometimes they just say stuff to say
stuff I understand that but broadly
speaking I'm going to look at the
rhetoric and the actions and I am going
to grade them the same so yes I would
hold Biden and Trump to the same stand
so my feeling is in this one area where
for clarification we're going to have a
division is that I of course don't treat
Trump's rhetoric in the same way that I
treat Biden's or Obama's he's utterly
uncalibrated he says whatever he wants
to at any given time and it doesn't even
match up with his policy very often can
I ask you like for our head of state our
chief executive shouldn't rhetoric be
arguably one of the most important
things that he does I mean the answer
would be yes and now I've been given a
choice between a person who I think in
calibrated ways says things that are
divisive and a person who in
uncalibrated ways says things that are
divisive and so the evidence that Joe
Biden is divisive is every poll taken
since essentially August of of 2021 he
he is by all available metrics
incredibly divisive a huge percentage of
Americans are deeply unhappy not only
with his performance but don't believe
he's a uniter they they're that that's
just the reality and that may just be a
reflection I mean honestly we may be
putting too much on Trump or Biden
personally it may just be that the
American people themselves are
rhetorically divided because of social
media and social media can in fact be
assess
one thing that I would ask you about
that though is I agree especially when
you look at the favorability but
sometimes when I look at these polls
when you start to disaggregate them by
party I wonder if it's actually is Biden
historically divisive or um I'm trying
to think of a really polite way to say
this the people that like Trump worship
Trump I don't know I like one of the
most precient things that Trump could
have probably ever said was that I could
kill someone on Fifth Street and nobody
would me accountable so is it really
that Biden isly divisive or is it that
every single Trump supporter will always
say that Trump is great and
the reason I would say that that Biden
is in fact historically divisive is
because Republicans felt much more
strongly about Barack Obama than Joe
Biden actually but they didn't feel as
strongly about Trump as they did about
like Romney or McCain right in in what
way I mean and the allegiance to Trump
oh no there's certainly more allegiance
to Trump there is to romir McCain
largely because Trump won in 2016 but
beyond that the the point that I'm
making is that if you're looking at the
stats in terms of divisiveness
Republicans always find the Democratic
president divisive the question is where
the rest of the country is and right now
there are a lot of Democrats who either
don't agree with Biden or you know find
him divisive there a lot of Independents
who find him divisive so when you're
when we're comparing these things I
don't think they're leagues apart in
terms of the divisive effects of what
they say right and and I'm separating
that off from like the inherent content
of what they say because obviously what
Trump says is is more divisive just on
like the raw level I mean if he's
insulting people as opposed to Joe Biden
doing Maga Republicans like if I were to
just if I an alien come down from space
and look at these two statements I'd say
this one's more divisive than this one
but then there's the reality of being a
human being in the world and is everyone
has baked Donald Trump into the cake and
Joe Biden again started off with a
patina of being non- divisive and now
has emerged as divisive I if you don't
mind I actually want to get to the the
foreign policy questions because this
one is actually slightly less
interesting to
me just one quick thing I guess like
because we can say the reality of it and
we can look at opinion polls what if we
look at like legislative accomplishments
like Biden is working on a 5050 divided
Senate Donald Trump had both house of
Congress and the Supreme Court and got
like no major legislation passed well I
mean he he he did lose Congress in 2018
but sure but prior to that because we
got the we got the infrastructure bill I
think in one year which Trump promised
for his entire presidency didn't get
anywhere on well I mean yes his his
Republican base was not in favor of mass
spending on infrastructure and neither
am I so there's that I think that mostly
a state local but they were in favor of
mass spending for tax guns that's not a
spending I mean we I mean effectively it
is right like effectively it's not well
if if you're cutting tax receipts but
you're not changing the level of
spending like Biden did with the uh Ira
again we we have a fundament
philosophical difference here I think
that when when the government takes my
money that it's not that is not the
government somehow being more fiscally
responsible and when the government
allows me to keep my money I don't see
that as the government spending I see
that as my money and the government is
taking less of it that's great but at
the end of the day the government is
still going to be in a deficit spending
and they're going to have to borrow
money from the treasury right we have a
spending problem in other words it's not
a receipts problem is the case that I'm
making but the problem with with Donald
Trump is not that he lowered taxes the
United States has one of the most
progressive tax systems on the planet
and in fact if you wish to have a
European style social welfare state what
you actually need is to tax the middle
class to death I mean the reality is the
top 20% of the American population pays
literally all net taxes in the United
States after after state benefits and
all of this so if if you actually wanted
to have the kind of social welfare state
that many liberals seem to want to have
like northern Europe for example you'd
actually have to tax people who make 40
$506,000 and I don't want that I agree
with that but how do you explain the
lack of legislation I mean if he's like
such a uniter because I think the
Republican Party itself is is quite
divided and I think that Trump but isn't
that his job he's the head of the
Republican Party he's the president
Republican president of the United
States I don't think that Joe Biden has
passed wildly historic legislation was
the largest like so here here's the
problem if you're a republican the only
bills that you can get consensus on tend
to be bills that either that that let's
be real about this that are tax cuts
because as you would I think agree with
when it comes to polling data Americans
constantly say they want to cut the
government and then the minute you ask
them which program they have no idea
what they're right exactly and so trying
to it's much harder to come up with a
bill to cut things than is to come up
with a bill to add things coming which
is why spending was out of control under
under Trump as well but there are some
Republicans who still don't want to
spend on those things right so
inherently the the task that this goes
back to the first question the task that
Republicans think government is there to
do is different than the task that
Democrats think that government is there
to do so the way that the very metric of
success for a Democratic president
versus a Republican president namely for
example pieces of legislation passed as
a republican one of my goals is to pass
nearly no legislation because I don't
actually want the government involved in
more areas of of our life I want to ask
a couple questions on the foreign policy
for yeah okay wait real quick just so
for instance like Donald Trump wanted to
punish China and he wanted to bring uh
microprocessor manufacturer of the
United States uh Biden did that with
legislation with a chips act uh you talk
about like spending being out of control
and I I mean I can agree with that I
think anybody that looks at the numbers
has to agree with that but why not pass
legislation like the inflation reduction
act um which is at least like spending
neutral right like why are there not
bills where Donald Trump could take well
I mean first of all I think that
whenever the government says something
spending neutral it rarely materializes
that way that is not going to be a
spending neutral bill but there's
difference between like at least they
say it's spending neutral versus this is
a $500 billion bill over like 10 years I
well but again I don't see a tax cut as
a matter of corent spending neutrality
the big problem is they keep spending
not that they are allowing me to keep
the money that I earned and they did not
earn but okay so then just to understand
so if somebody just did massive like
reductions in tax receipts so tax cut
after tax C after tax cut but they
didn't change spending at all you
wouldn't consider that like an increase
in deficit spending or out of control
spending you would just say they're just
tax cuts no the opposite I I would
consider it a wild I I would consider it
a wild overspending okay meaning so then
was it under Trump then when he did the
tax I mean the spending by the way under
under Biden is way worse than it was
under of course but we're in postco
right Co ended effectively I mean you
live in Florida Co effectively ended in
the State of Florida by the middle of
2021 I me if you're vacc fan by like
April May of 2021 there was wide
availability of vaccines whether or not
you like the vaccines and at that point
we were done I agree but like we're in a
post like how many trillions of dollars
have been dumped in worldwide that are
like leading to inflation right
inflation is like a worldwide uh issue
right now because of the economy
shutting down for a year or two it's not
like those effects are gone in one year
right Co might be gone but the after
effects of all the stimulus spending and
the unemployment everything else the
definition of inflation is too much
money chasing too few goods so pouring
more money on top of that makes for more
inflation that's what it does sure I
agree um but like there's also the
definition of when do you deficit spend
is when economies are headed for
recessions right rather than when
economies are doing really well like
they were under Trump and he was deficit
spending whereas Biden can at least make
the argument that I should I ought to be
deficit spending because the economy is
heading for potential recession the
thing I don't think that the economy was
actually headed for recession in in fact
if you look at the economics St
Economist said they it was every
Economist they're still saying that
there's like a recession coming right
right but that that was largely because
of the after effects of inflation
meaning if you inflate the economy what
you are going to end up doing is
bursting a bubble and then when that
Bubble Burst you'll get a recession I
mean that was the basic idea right the
idea the question was whether you're
going to get the soft Landing but if you
actually look at for example the
employment statistics or the economic
growth statistics in the United States
what they look like under the last
year's Obama and then Trump I mean this
is what the chart looks like is it looks
like this and then it hits March of 2020
it goes like that yeah right and then by
like September it bounces back up right
it's a v-shaped recovery and then it
starts to Peter out sure a lot because
of the American Recovery plan right that
Biden did as well I mean four million
jobs yeah no I don't I'm not going to
attribute it to that because this the
rates of growth in in job growth from
September October November were actually
very similar to the rates of job growth
after Joe Biden took office what you see
is actually kind of a straight line I
mean what the chart looks like in any
case Okay so on the foreign policy stuff
this getting upu but on the foreign
policy stuff um so the the questions
that I have with regard to to Biden on
foreign policy uh very very simple
question do you think that the situation
in the Middle East is better now than it
was under Donald
Trump
probably um that's a hard one the
factors that I'm making right now are
like obviously you've got the Israel
Palestinian War that's going on right
now which is kind of bad but like
broadly speaking I'm not sure how much
that affects the Middle East as much as
like the collapse of Syria 2013 Syrian
Civil War sent millions of immigrants
throughout all of Europe which was under
um which was under Obama and continued
under Trump trump didn't do anything to
alleviate any of the Syrian Civil War um
in ter why did Syria end up as a
Preserve of Russia again how did Syria
end up as a Preserve of Russia yes why
did it end up being essentially a client
state of Russia um I know that Putin
enjoys access to the ports down there um
I don't know you're I mean the reason is
because Barack Obama suggested that
there was a red line that would be drawn
in the face of chemical weapons used
Bashar Assad then used chemical weapons
in Syria and Barack Obama was UN
unwilling to then essentially create
consequences for Syria in the form of
any sort of Western strike and so
instead he outsourced it to Russia this
is 2013 2014 sure do you think there
might have been some hesitancy after
like seeing how Libya ended up that
maybe us like intervening presid during
Libya Obama yeah I mean like sure but
what does that have to do with anything
though I'm just saying there might have
been like a mistake learned that
actually the Middle East I mean just
historically speaking was historically
good under Donald Trump I mean it's very
difficult to make Decay that either
before or after Trump were better than
during Donald Trump the Syrian I don't
think that that Trump contributed to the
Syrian situation improving much um I
think wreck Isis which was in the I mean
Isis had been getting wrecked by the
Kurds in Iraq by every single person by
Assad's Army by Putin by turkey
literally everybody was fighting against
Isis at that point there there was a
spike in violence and then the the Trump
I mean you get credit for when you're
president presumably I mean things got
better with Isis under Trump I mean yeah
they did I mean things got worse with
Isis under Obama they for sure he called
them the JV Squad and then they became
not the JV Squad yeah but I don't know
if Isis is originating in Syria um and
uh baghdaddy and all of the growth of
that is necessarily Obama's fault I know
that we like to say that Obama created
Isis I don't know if you say that but
I've heard that saying a lot I think
that's a little bit simplistic um I I
don't think that when I'm looking at
like actions that presidents have taken
the the big the biggest criticism I have
for like Middle Eastern policy is I
think the Doha Accords were a disaster
and I think that's like one of the
biggest blemishes that we have right now
I would also argue that moving the um
Embassy to Jerusalem was also kind of
silly um and arguably contributed to
some of the conflict we see right now
between I'll argue precisely the
opposite especially given the fact that
after the movement of the embassy to
Jerusalem the Abraham Accords continued
to sign and actually expand and that if
Donald Trump had been elected I have no
doubt in my mind that Saudi Arabia would
now be a part of the Abraham Accords in
fact that was basically pre-negotiated
uh and then when joee Biden took office
Joe Biden took a very anti-saudi stand
on a wide variety of issues the the
biggest single effect in the Middle East
of Joe Biden's presidency and again I
agree with you that not every foreign
policy issue can be laid at the hands of
a President Joe Biden's main approach to
the Middle East was very similar to the
Obama approach which is why the Middle
East was chaotic under Obama and chaotic
under Biden and that was to alienate
allies like Saudi Arabia and Israel and
instead to try to make common cause or
cut deals with Iran what that did is
disincentivized terrorism from Iran what
we're watching in the Middle East is
Iran attempting to use every one of its
Terror proxies in the Middle East and it
was specifically launched in an attempt
to avoid what Biden actually was trying
to do which was good which was after two
years of failure with Saudi Arabia try
to bring them into the Abraham Accords
right that was what was burgeoning at
the end of La at the end of last year
and Iran saw that and Iran decided that
they were going to throw a grenade into
the middle of those negotiations by
essentially activating Hamas Hamas
activates Kamas commits October 7th
Israel as a sovereign nation state has
to respond to the murder of 1200 of its
Cien and the taking kidnapping of of 240
Israel has to do that not only to go
after its own hostages and try to
restore them but also to reestablish
military deterrence in the most violent
region of the world hisbah gets active
on Israel's northern border kisah is an
Iranian proxy they get active on the
northern border the the hthis in Yemen
get active these are all the only reason
all this is happening at the same time
is because Iran is doing this right not
just that they're they are threatening
global Shipping if you're talking about
the effects of global supply lines which
I totally agree had a major inflationary
effect on the economy than to right now
the cost of shipping is nearly double
what it was just a few weeks ago and
that is because a rag tag group of H The
Barbarians are attacking international
shipping and forcing everybody to stop
using the Babel M Freight instead going
around the Cape of Good Hope in in
Africa all of that is the result of the
fact that Joe Biden reoriented the
United States in the very early days in
favor of a more pro-iranian stance he
appointed Robert Maly to negotiate the
Iran deal who as it turns out was using
proxies many of his AIDS were actually
taking money from Iran
the the the Biden Administration
literally one of their first acts was to
delist the hoodies as a terror
organization and end sanctions against
the hoodies these are all moves that
that Biden made very early on they were
disastrous moves but when it comes to
domestic policy I think he hasn't been
nearly as damaging domestic policy has
on foreign sure sure so just on a couple
of Middle Eastern things so one of the
big things that threw the Middle East
into disaster was we are all traumatized
by it now was the Iraq evasion CH
Republican president sure agre with that
right the the deposition of Saddam
Hussein and everything that follow after
probably contributed more to the growth
of Isis and the dilation of that entire
region probably more than anything else
I think that under prior to Bush um for
Clinton and even at the beginning of
Bush's presidency we were on some kind
of road to normaly um with Iran which I
think has to happen whether we like them
or not um until Bush for whatever reason
decides to throw Iran into the axis of
Evil and me that we're on a road to
normaly with Iran in the 1990s we do in
the wait what that we on a road to
normaly with Iran in the 1990s my
understanding is that yeah from the late
90s and prior to the AIS of
labeling of Iran that there was going to
be someth forward to where we could
start to normalize relationships with
them I I I find that very difficult to
believe and I don't see a lot of
evidence I mean we can just disagree on
that okay yeah sure we can disagree on
that but I know that the after effect
just quick note the after effect of the
Iraq war that was the most devastating
was the increase in power of Iran I
agree yeah because of the
destabilization of Iraq and Iraq not
having a uh a government there that was
functional for at least a decade and was
in fact Sunni government right
originally it was Sunni government
disbanding the the Sunni Army was one of
the worst things that the bush
all the
former yeah all horrible under
Republican president um that the uh yeah
that that probably contributed more to
Isis uh to the growth of power in Iran
maybe even to the decivilization of
Syria probably more than anything that
Obama did um also the uh when we look at
Iran funding people in the region I
don't disagree with that as well I think
Iran is the number one instigator of bad
guy things right now in the Middle East
Iran um the irgc I supported when Donald
Trump killed simman I think that was a
great thing um I I think that Iran is a
major problem however I don't know if
the path forward is constantly being a
belligerent to Iran or trying to figure
out some road to normaly I don't know if
the collapse of Iran um or the
destruction of that country considering
how unpopular the iol even is there like
the citizens of Iran I don't think are
big supporters of the government there
um I I feel like moving on a path where
you know let's do our nuclear
inspections we had that um Iranian
nuclear deal that Trump pulled out of
let's do the nuclear inspections make
sure you're not on a way to nuclear
weapons let's unfree some funds let's
move in some Direction Where We Get on a
good term with you I feel like that's
the most important thing that needs to
happen in the Middle East as much as
people like to look at the Abraham
Accords who cares if what was it uh
Bahrain I think Oman um I think the UAE
and Morocco yeah AR like all of these
people even Saudi Arabia already have
like de facto normalization with Israel
anyway they're all trading this I mean
to to pretend that that anybody even 15
years ago would have been talking about
normalization between Saudi Arabia and
Israel is insane they already they were
already on that path they had already
been tra they were already de facto
trading partners with each other that
that they had already been collaborating
a wild claim that that Israel and Saudi
Arabia were going to normalize 15 years
ago 15 years ago might have been a wild
CL but after Turkey um after Jordan and
then in the past like 20 years of like
economic relations and ties with each
other all of the leadership in the
Middle East and you'll agree with this
look at Israel and they go okay well
we've got Palestinians who you know God
bless them do nothing and then you've
got Israel which is on a on a region
with no natural resources to somehow
become like an economic giant they're
good to trade with they're relations
educated they you know have military
power um all of the leadership in these
Middle Eastern countries are wanting to
be friendly with Israel and are engaging
in trade de facto with Israel and the
idea that like the UAE and bahin were
brought in to say like oh well now we're
going to officially say this I I I just
those those were the first steps toward
obviously the formation of a new Middle
East in which economics would
predominate over sectarian conflict the
chief obstacle to that is Iran AG the
notion that you that that negotiations
with the Ayatollah were going to be a
solution to any of this is but do we
think absolutely are the is it the
Abraham Accords that's convincing Saudi
Arabia to take a stance against Iran no
I mean Saab they're already fighting
with each other right like I don't think
the abam ofs moved us any closer towards
any type of real peace in the region has
to happen is something has to happen
with Iran there has to be some
diplomatic bilateral communication there
no what has to happen is the containment
of Iran which was what was in which was
what was taking place with the increased
normalization with the Sunni Arab world
and Israel combined with significant
economic sanctions they the notion that
that there's this far-fetched notion in
in foreign policy circles that diplomacy
can sort of be wish cast out of thin air
that if you sit around a table that you
can always come to an agreement with
somebody the ayatolla do not have common
interests with the United States they do
not and this idea that they are willing
to take money in exchange for for
example some sort of PE peaceful
acquiescence to Israel's existence is
obviously untrue Lally hasn't that been
the case though that you've had a region
with tons of sectarian violence for a
long time and then finally turkey was
like you know what this isn't worth it
the United States paid him a lot of
money they had conversations with Israel
you know what the the economy the
economic
GS with Jordan same with into Turkish
politics but the but but the the
situation with turkey was actually quite
warm between Israel and Turkey in the
90s when you had the the you know sort
of secular Muslim
regime Turk in place and and now erdogan
is has joined in the freight and erdogan
is significantly more radical than what
before
um if I said tur Egypt my bad yeah egpt
yeah so in terms of like Egypt and
Jordan right were the first two so you
here's the thing you need is it possible
that you could theoretically come to a
deal with Iran only with a new
leadership crew okay this is true for
every peace agreement in the region you
you could not Israel could not have made
peace with well they made peace with
Egypt and and Sadat was the leader for
Yom kapor right he did not make peace
with Naser right the point is that this
is a different regime you need a
different regime this the same regime
that did the part of the y kapor war was
the same regime that negotiated peace
with Israel I mean that's true it is
also true that that is a relationship
that could be cultivated specifically
because it was sadad who made clear he
was going to come to the table have the
Iranians ever made clear that they would
come to the table over for example the
existence of the state of Israel uh no
that is not a thing that's going to
happen but I think peoplea every every
single one of their proxy every one of
them not only calls for the destruction
of the state of Israel they also call
for the destruction of America I mean
this is literally the houie slogan
they're busy hitting ships and their
slogan is literally ALU Akbar death to
America death to the Jews death to
Israel it doesn't fit on a bumper
sticker but that and it's not all that
catchy but that is in fact their slogan
the notion that the regime that
propagates that is going to be
approached with diplomacy is not only
wrong the problem is that we it's easy
to say the stakes of diplomacy are are
okay so we try to talk right jaw jaw is
better than war war sure the only
problem is that in the Middle East
weakness is taken as a sign that
aggression might be an appropriate
response that is how things work in the
Middle East and the fact that Barack
that that Joe Biden rather came into
office with an orientation toward
continuing the Biden the the Obama
policies in Iran has led to
conflagrations these sort of brush fires
breaking out everywhere that Iran has
borders with either the west or Israel
or both right any place that's happening
it's leading to brushfires because again
the logic of violence in the Middle East
is not quite the logic of violence in
other places in the world by the way I
think the logic of vs in the m east is
actually closer to what most
International politics looks like than
we than we wish that it were I mean I
think that's part of what's happening in
Ukraine as well so you think which
brings me by the way here's my question
about Ukraine just real quick you so you
think that for Iran right a country that
has been sanctioned for God knows how
many years now you think that for Iran
just continuing to sanction them and
contain them is an effective way is more
effective than trying to engage them in
bilateral and multilateral peace talks
yes 100% And the proof is in the pudding
before we go to Ukraine can ask about
Israel so you're both mostly in
agreement but what is I don't know if
I'd say that okay but as I'm learning uh
what is Israel doing right what is
Israel doing wrong in this very specific
current war in
Gaza um I mean frankly I think that what
Israel is doing wrong is if I were
Israel okay like again America's
interests are not coincident with
Israel's interests if if if I were an
Israeli leader I would have swiveled up
and I would have knocked the leap out of
hisbah early does does so I I would have
I would yov Galant who's the defense
minister of Israel was encouraging
netanyahu's the Prime Minister and the
war cabin including Benny Gan so
whenever people talk about the Netanyahu
government that's not what's in place
right now there's a Unity War government
in place that includes the political
opposition the reason I point that out
is because there are a lot of people
politically who will suggest that the
actions Israel is currently taking are
somehow the manifestation of a
right-wing government Israel currently
does not have a quotequote rightwing
government they have Unity government
that includes the opposition in any case
yov Galant was urging in the very early
days of the war that Israel should turn
north and instead of hitting Hamas they
should actually take the opportunity to
knock hisbah out because hisbah is
significantly more dangerous to the
existence of the state of Israel than
Hamas I actually agree with that uh as
far as what Israel has been doing wrong
in the actual War I mean I think
that again from an American perspective
I think that Israel is is doing pretty
well from an Israeli perspective fire
Israeli I would actually want Israel to
be less loose about sending its soldiers
in on the ground level so Israel's
attempting to minimize civilian
casualties and the cost of that has been
the highest military death toll that
Israel has had since the 1973 Yore War I
mean I personally know through one
degree of separation three separate
people have been killed in Gaza and
that's because they're going in door
Todo it's because they're they're
attempting to minimize civilian
casualties and they're losing a lot of
guys in in this particular in this
particular War um you know the the the
problem that Israel has had historically
speaking is that Israel got very
complacent about its own security
situation they believe the technology
was is going to somehow correct for the
hatred on the other side of the wall
that very okay so our people have to
live underground for two weeks at a time
while some Rockets fall but at least
it's not a war and that complacence you
know bred what happened on October 7th
so to me what Israel did wrong was years
and years and years of complacence and
belief in an Oslo system that is at root
a failure because you cannot make a
peace agreement with people who do not
want make peace with you so that that
that's what I think Israel is doing
wrong I I have a feeling there's going
to be wide Divergence on this point
um maybe uh so in terms of broadly
speaking um I generally oppose
settlement expansion is a thing that
Israel does incorrectly that I think is
kind of like provocative to at least all
the Palestinians uh in the West Bank and
I probably energizes hatred and the Gaza
trip for them as well in terms of
conducting uh in terms of conducting
Warfare uh the one thing that I always
say to everybody uh especially Americans
is you can't evaluate things from an
American perspective it's very stupid
happened a lot with Ukraine where people
like oh well didn't they work with the
Nazis and like weren't the Soviets the
good guys and it's like well in in other
parts of the world it's not quite as
simple um and I think the same is true
for isra Palestine that a lot of
Americans will analyze the conflict as
just being one between only Israel and
Palestine which is not it's a conflict
between Israel and then Palestine hasah
the houthis and Iran right now it is um
I think that the however one area where
I'll break with Ben is is I think that
minimizing civilian casualties and
everything is very very very important I
think on the Israeli side I don't think
it's important so that the US will stay
with them cuz I think the US is probably
going to stick with Israel as long as
they don't do anything crazy and I don't
even think it matters for the
International Community it doesn't
definitely doesn't matter for the UN
because Jesus Christ um however I think
it's really really really important that
I think that in the Middle East broadly
speaking I think that leadership
especially in the Gulf has gotten over
the Palestinian uh issue I think that
leadership is kind of like they don't
care as much anymore but the populations
still care quite a bit and I think that
the main issue Israel could run into is
if the civilian death toll does climb
too high and if they start to hit this
you know 40 50 60,000 number of Civilian
casualties they run the risk of the
civilian populations and the surrounding
middle eastern states becoming so
antagonistic towards Israel that they
start to take steps back towards
normalization in the region so for
instance I know that um Bahrain I think
already pulled out their Ambassador um
to Israel my guess is going to be its
temporary um I know that on the um on
the public speaking side you've got a
lot of people condemning Israel for the
attacks and on the private side you've
got people telling Israel please kill
all of Hamas because this is untenable
and nobody wants to work in the
situation um I don't know if this ended
up being true or not I'm guessing it
didn't but I saw on a couple of Twitter
accounts it was leaked that potentially
Saudi Arabia was considering installing
a government in the West Bank that they
would run um no I mean I I think Israel
would love nothing better than that but
that is something one of the big
problems in the Middle East is literally
no one wants to preside over the
Palestinians no one in the Arab states
Israel no one I think the issue is and I
think and I'm largely actually I'm very
sympathetic towards the Palestinians
because I think that for um since 48 and
onwards I think that all of the Arab
states super gassed them up on that they
wanted the Palestinians to fight because
they wanted to fight with Israel um
however as time has gone on and they
realized that the it's kind of a lost
cause states have started to drop out so
you're getting these bilateral uh peace
treaties with um Egypt and with Jordan
you're getting multilateral agreements
like the Abraham Accords and now the
Palestinians are looking around and like
okay well you guys told us to fight all
this time and now the only people that
we have support putting us our Iranian
proxies um so the Palestinians are in a
very weird spot where they've like lost
all their support um yeah I think that I
think that Israel what I would say to be
quote unquote critical of Israel is
Israel needs to take strong steps
towards peace that probably involves
them enduring some undue hardship so not
the October 7th attacks because Jesus
that's way too much but you know other
types of you know attacks that they
might have to deal with that might cause
some civilians to die that they don't
come out over the top with and and
retaliate with if there's ever going to
be peace in that region however the
another thing that I've always said is a
huge problem between Israel and
Palestine is I think that both sides
think that if they continue to fight it
will be good for them but the problem is
one side is delusional uh Israel I think
Israel wants to continue to fight
because they get justifications for uh
the annexation of the Golan Heights they
get justifications for expansions
especially into area sea that I that
think they're probably going to try to
Annex soon uh they get justifications
for the increased military posturing uh
towards the Gaza Strip and the embargos
and Israel is right that if the conflict
continues really the situation only
improves for Israel Over time but the
Palestinians also all believe that if
they keep fighting they thought this
since 2000 under Arafat that if they
just keep fighting they'll get better
gains too but that's not the case is
there a difference between Palestinian
citizens and the leadership when you say
that I love all people I love all people
around the world and I think that when
we analyze issues I think that we have
to be very honest with what the people
on the ground think and the idea that
Hamas is just this one-off thing in the
Gaza Strip is not only incorrect with
the situation on the ground it's also
incredibly ahistorical um and the idea
that like the Palestinians in the West
Bank of which I believe the most recent
polling shows I want to say 75 to 80%
support the October 7th attacks um
Palestinians in general want to fight in
violent conflict with Israel that's not
just the position of the government
that's not just people there's a reason
why aboss doesn't want to do uh
elections in the West Bank uh and it's
because the Palestinian people really do
want to fight with Israel but to combat
that problem is like you have to get the
UN on board we've got to do an actual
addressing of the Palestinian refugee
problem which is handled like a joke
right now um Iran has to be brought to
the table in terms of negotiations uh
there has to be huge efforts made to
economically Revitalize these like
Palestinian areas even though they're
one of the highest recipients of Aid in
the world um you you have to do
something about the Embargo and the
blockade and the Gaza Strip which isn't
just maintained by Israel it's also
maintained by Egypt you should ask why
um yeah there's a lot of things that
have to happen to fix that problem but
the reality is is I don't think isra
really wants to because they get to
continue their expansion into the West
Bank and I don't think anybody around
the world really cares that much month
we won't be talking I will argue with
that the idea that Israel does not want
to end the conflict is be lied by the
history of what just happen with the
Gaza Strip so when we talk about
settlements for example Israel did have
settlements inside the Gaza Strip there
were 8,000 Jews were living inside the
Gaza Strip in gush katif uh up until
2005 they they they withdrew all of
those people I mean took them literally
out of their homes uh and the result was
not the burgeoning of a of a better
attitude toward the state of Israel with
regard to for example you know the the
Palestinian population in Gaza in fact
it was more radical in Gaza than it was
in the West Bank uh the the the result
was obviously the election of Hamas the
the October 7th attacks in which
unfortunately many civilians took place
took part in the October 7th attacks
there's video of people rushing who are
civilians and dressed in civilian
clothing into Israeli Villages not
always the same thing oh no no that that
is 100% true obviously uh and when it
comes to you know area C and Israel's
you know oppos a deep and abiding desire
for territorial expansion in area area C
so for for those who are not familiar
with the oso C and again this is getting
very abstruse but the Oslo Accords are
broken down into three areas of the West
Bank area a is under full Palestinian
control that' be like Janine and abbl
the the major cities for example there's
area B which is mixed Israeli
Palestinian control where Israel
provides some level of military security
and control uh and then there's area C
and area C was like to be decided later
it was left up for possible concessions
to the Palestinian Authority if the oso
cords had moved forward those are
disputed territories there is building
taking place in areas he by both
actually no one talks about this but by
by Palestinians as well as Israelis uh
and the the you know question is to
whether if Israel stopped building there
have been many settlement freees in the
past including some undertaken by
Netanyahu uh and and it actually has not
done one iota of good in moving the ball
forward in terms of actual negotiations
again the the biggest problem is that
the leadership for Palestinians has
spent every day since really 67 it's not
even 48 because after 40 between 48 and
67 Jordan was in charge of the West Bank
and Egypt was in charge of the Gaza
Strip and at no point did either of
those pow say hey maybe we ought to hand
this over to an independent Palestinian
state which was originally the division
that was that was promoted by the UN
partition plan in
47 because of that uh the the leadership
post 67 and really starting in 64 the
Palestine Liberation Organization was
founded in ' 64 and it called for the
liberation of the land in ' 64 they had
the West Bank and they had the Gaza
strimp so they're talking about Tel Aviv
uh when it was founded in in' 64 the
basic idea as you know kind of indicated
by that was Israel will not exist and
that was a promise that's been made by
pretty much every Palestinian leader in
Arabic to the people that they are
talking to Yas arat famously would do
this sort of thing he'd speak in English
and talk about how he wanted a two-state
solution and then he'd go back to his
own people and say this is a trojan
horse and we're if Israel could if you
think that Israeli parents want to send
their kids at the age of
to go and monitor Janine and Nablus and
be in inun you're out of your mind
you're out of your mind Israelis do not
want that in fact Israelis didn't want
that so much that they allowed Rockets
to fall in their cities for full on 18
years in order to avoid sending soldiers
on mass back into the Gaza Strip true
but I think Israel does want to continue
to expand settlements into the West Bank
right they want to continue to build
they want to have all Jerusalem East
Jerusalem as well well I mean East
Jerusalem has already been annexed so
East Jerusalem is according to Israel a
part of Israel that's not a settlement
okay so there there's that with regard
to you know does Israel have an interest
in expanding settlements in the West
Bank why would they not until there's a
peace partner sure that's what I mean
but I'm saying as long as the conflict
continues like because even when you
talk about no but your suggestion is
that they're incentivizing the conflict
to continue so they can grab more land
well no let me be very clear I don't
think there's like a like so some people
say for instance uh they'll take that
one quote from Netanyahu and they'll try
to say that like he was funding the
people in the Gaza Strip by allowing
katari money to come in even though he
was actually speaking in opposition to a
boss allowing the gusa strip to fall for
Netanyahu to clear it out for him and
they give it back etc etc I'm not saying
I'm not claiming those theories I'm just
saying that I think that Israel will
take a relatively neutral stance towards
conflict enduring because as long as the
conflict endures and as long as the uh
settlements can expand I think that
benefits I think that ultimately
benefits Israel the I think there would
be very let's put this way if suddenly
there arose among the Palestinians a
deep and abiding desire for peace
approved by a vast majority of the
population with serious security
guarantees I think you'd be very
hardpressed to find Israelis who would
not be willing to at least consider that
in return for not expanding bathrooms in
aat
I would have agreed with you on October
6 I think we're probably a year or two
away from that right now no no but the
point I'm making is that Israelis now
realize that the entire peace process
was a sham meaning the people who are on
the other side of the table were using
it as a trojan horse in the first place
the the death of Oslo is not the death
of Israeli hopefulness it's the death of
the illusion that on the other side of
the table was anyone worth bargaining
with that's what's happening and that's
why you have this sort of insane
disconnect right now between the United
States and the Israeli government again
it's a Unity government no one in Israel
is talking about making concessions to
the Palestinian Authority for WI variety
of reasons including the fact that
Mahmud abas fat continues to pay actual
families of terrorists who kill
Jews right and and the which from the
the moderate West Bank right exactly
that's that so you again like the taste
in Israel for this is a even the people
who are the the kilon right those are
the most secular people in Israel which
was by the way the place that was
attacked on October 7th I mean what
people should understand is that October
7th was not an attack against
settlements in the West Bank it was an
attack on peace Villages that were
essentially disarmed and many of these
people who were killed were peace
activists were literally trying to work
with people in Gaza to get them I mean
it's just it's it's mindboggling that's
why you had this ground shift in Israel
the next 20 years in Israel is going to
be about security and economic
development period end of story
everything else goes second third place
and I will say I agree essentially with
everything you're saying um not to loop
back on another topic but this is one of
the reasons then why I was so critical I
don't want to say critical but like kind
of nonchalant about the Abraham Accords
because they didn't address anything
with the Palestinians whatsoever they
brought in countries that weren't super
relevant to the conflict they didn't
bring in Qatar which is where a lot of
the money support for the god con they
didn't involve Iran at all they involved
bilateral totally changed the mentality
and this is why what I'm seeing right
now this is why listen I think that that
Biden has done better than I certainly
expected him to do in terms of support
for Israel like Obama was way less
supportive of Israel than Biden by every
metric with that said the Redick that
he's been using recently and that
blankin have been using recently about
Israel needs to make painful concessions
for peace Israel reentering this issue
at the center of relations in the Middle
East is doomed to failure the magic
magic is a strong word the the benefit
of the Abraham Accords was proof of what
you're saying which is true which is
that all the surrounding countries in
reality have abandoned the idea that
there is a centrality to the Palestinian
Israeli conflict that is not the central
conflict in the Middle East and by the
way one of the reasons it's not the
central conflict in the Middle East is
because actually ironically because of
the rise of Iran right it's it's Sunni
states that are largely signing up with
Israel because they're realizing they
need some sort of counterweight to a a
burgeoning nuclear power in
Iran can we talk about Ukraine sure you
have a disagreement with uh with with
what uh Destiny said my my main problem
with Biden's policy with regard to
Ukraine is that he outsourced the end
goal of the war to zalinski early on now
that might make sense if that goal were
something that he was willing to fund to
the point of achievement uh or if zinski
could have achieved it on his own but
right now and this has been true since
pretty early on the war Point Henry kiss
gerid uh this that that pretty early on
in the war was very clear that for
example CR was going nowhere the
Russians had control of Crimea barring
the United States giving permission to
fly f16s over Crimea nothing was going
to change over there the same thing was
true in most of the donbas right in
luhansk and DK that that was not going
to change zalinsky stated goal and you
understand it he's a leader of Ukraine
right is is that there was a predation
on his territory in 2014 and that the
Russians sent their little green men
across the border and then they took all
of these areas and so he is the leader
of Ukraine is saying okay I want all of
that back now the reality is that the
US's interest had largely been achieved
in the first few months of the war
meaning the revocation of the ability of
Russia to take Ukraine and just ingest
it and two the devastation of of
Russia's military capability I mean
Russia has just been wrecked I mean
their military is in serious Straits
because of the war in Ukraine from an
American perspective I'm very much Pro
all of that I think that we have an
interest in Ukraine maintaining a buffer
status against territorially aggressive
Russia I think that the United States
does have an interest in degrading the
Russian military to the extent that it
can't threaten the Baltic states or
threaten Kazakhstan or other countries
in the region the problem I have with
Biden's strategy is as always I think
that it's a muddle and I think muddles
tend to end with misperceptions war
tends to break out and maintain because
of misperception misperception of the
other side strength the other side's
intentions and and all of the rest
people misperceive what's going to
happen they say I I'll cross that line
and nothing will happen right this is
what Putin thought he thought I'll cross
that line they'll GRE me as a liberator
and because the United States just
surrendered in Afghanistan essentially
they won't do anything and the West is
fragmenting NATO's fragmenting and all
the rest of this and obviously he was
wrong on on all of those scores the
problem for for Biden is that as with
virtually every war no end line was set
and so it became out recently that it
was widely reported that actually there
was a peace deal that was on the table
in the first few months that Putin was
on board with uh that basically would
have seeded luhansk and denet and Crimea
to Russia in return for solidification
of those lines American and Western
Security guarantees to Ukraine right
Ukraine wouldn't formally join NATO but
there would be security guarantees to
Ukraine we're ending up there anyway
it's just taking a lot more money and a
lot more time to get there and do you
think Trump would have helped push that
piece yes and I think and I think that
Biden actually did zalinski a bit of a
disservice because zalinski knows where
this war is going to end and it's not
going to end with luhansk denes and
Crimea in Ukrainian hands it's just not
going to and he knows that what actually
in my opinion zilinski needed was for
Joe Biden to be the person who foed that
deal upon him so that he could then go
back to his own people and say listen
guys I wanted those things but the
Americans weren't willing to allow me to
have all those things and so we did an
amazing job we did a heroic job in
defending our own land we devastated the
Russian military even though no one
expected us to but we can't get back
those things because it's unrealistic to
get back those things because America
basically their big funer and they're
the ones who want the deal instead what
Biden said and this was reported in the
Washington Post last year the Biden
Administration said we're going to fight
for as long as it takes with as much as
it takes and when they were asked until
when they said whatever zalinsky says
and
that's not a policy that's just a recipe
for a frozen conflict with endless
funding now it may be that Putin's
walked away from the table and that deal
is no longer available if that deal is
is available right now I certainly hope
that's being pursued behind closed doors
my main critique again of Biden is that
when you Outsource the end goal to
another country without stating what
America's interest is that's a problem I
also think that Biden did really quite a
poor job of sort of explaining what
America's realistic interests are I I I
don't like it when American leaders um
it's weird for me to say this but I'm
not a huge fan of the we're in it to
protect democracy kind of rhetoric
because frankly we are allied with many
many countries that are not democracies
and that's not actually how foreign
policy Works uh we should as an overall
you know 30,000 foot goal Advanced
democracy and and rights where we can
but the reason that we were
fighting in favor of Ukraine and when I
say fighting I mean giving them money
and giving them Weaponry the reason that
we were doing that in favor of Ukraine
is not because
of Ukraine's long history of clean
voting and non-c Corruption the reason
that we were doing that is to counter
Russian interest in the region I mean
that was it was a pure real politic play
and that real politic play is hard to
deny no matter what side of the aisle
you're on I think that what many
Americans are going to are reverting to
is we have no interest there why are we
spending money there and not spending
money here and that that kind of stuff
and that that argument can always be
applied unless you actually articulate
the reason why it is good for Americans
Beyond simply the ideological for the
United States to be involved in a thing
so for example I think right now when
when Biden is talk I think that what
Biden just did he's the United States as
we speak is striking the houthis I think
that that's a really really good thing I
think that's a necessary thing I think
American people should understand why
that is happening it's not because of
quote unquote ideology it is I mean on a
on a very root level but really it's
because you're you're screwing up the
Straits I mean you can't you can't do
that you can't screw up free trade and
Americans have an interest in not seeing
all of our prices at the grocery store
double and triple because a bunch of
ragtag pirates you know akin to the the
barber pirates from 18 00 are are
bothering everyone right so Ben said a
lot there do you disagree with any
aspect on the Ukraine side the um a
little bit yeah um I think on the macro
I agree maybe we get into we a little
bit on some things I on the final thing
that he said though I wish that
Americans could have honest
conversations about foreign policy I
think that it would just be better for
everybody um I don't know if it's uh you
know Red Scare after the Cold War where
it was like literally you know the
behemoths you know we're fighting
against communism and we felt like after
91 every single foreign policy decision
needs to be able to be explained in like
seven words like he's the bad guy and
that's it um I wish we had more honest
conversations about uh what our foreign
policy interest is in a particular
region because I don't think most
Americans honestly could even articulate
why Israel would be an important Ally or
why it's important to defend Ukraine
against Russia or why should we care
about Taiwan at all I don't know if most
Americans could articulate anything
there um even though they might have
very strong opinions about why uh we
ought to be involved in certain
conflicts so I do agree with that I wish
we had more honest conversations about
uh foreign policy um in terms of how
Biden has handled Ukraine my the things
that I liked the most were one that he
was very clear in the beginning about
what we wouldn't do so Biden saying that
we're not going to do um uh not a red
line no fly zones over Ukraine we're not
going to be deploying troops on the
ground in Ukraine we're not going to be
doing anything that would have you know
US soldiers and Russian soldiers
crossing swords with each other that's
not going to happen I like that he made
that very clear at the beginning um and
I like that the Coalition built between
NATO and the EU to get people to send uh
funds training soldiers airplanes and
everything to Ukraine I thought those
two things are really good in terms of
basically writing zalinsky a blank check
I would like to hope that Biden and the
entire United States learned a lesson
from Iraq and Afghanistan that
open-ended missions with unlimited
budgets and no clear goal are like the
worst foreign policy decisions you can
ever do they've like defined US foreign
policy for the past two or three decades
which is unfortunate but seems to be the
case um my my feeling would be and this
is just a feeling I don't know if
internal cables have leaked that say
otherwise is the uh the Biden
Administration has probably always had a
quiet position of at some point there's
going to be an off-ramp here and I think
even a month or two ago I think those
talks were being leaked that discussion
had begun with zalinsky looking for an
offramp but publicly of course the
United States is never going to come out
and say we are going to support you guys
to fight as much as you want for three
months and then after that it's no more
obviously that can't be the statement
it's always going to be that we're going
to support you in your fight against
Russia for under Obama with Afghanistan
it was terrible yeah you escalate The
Troop levels to X but only for 6 months
and then we're yeah you you just can't
do that it's always going to come off is
we're going to support you forever and
as long as it takes and as long as you
need whatever we have to do to defend
freedom and democracy in your country
and any any other statement would be
absurd so I can understand why it feels
like on a public level a blank check and
an indefinite time period was granted to
zalinsky but I don't think that's going
to be the case I think I again I hope
we've learned our lessons in the Middle
East about the forever Wars that this
isn't going to be a forever funding to
Ukraine to fight for as long as as they
want um I do disagree I feel like we're
playing a little bit retrospectively
saying that like well it's obvious that
they're not going to capture the Da Boss
it's obvious that they're not going to
capture Crimea I agree for Crimea that
was incredibly obvious but it was also
really obvious that in two weeks Russia
would own Kev and Ukraine was going to
be Belarus 2.0 I think that even for a
lot of uh military people um and
analysts around the world uh that that
that was an expectation or at least a
significant probability nobody knew uh
the phrase that's thr right now is paper
tiger that Russia's military was as
equipped as they were so I can
understand why especially if you're
Ukraine and if you've repelled an
invasion from one of the world's largest
armies why you might feel like well
it you know let's fight for a few months
let's fight for a year let's see what
happens and I can understand the United
States supporting them but I agree that
there has to be some reasonable offramp
where we're not going to fight forever I
think the US um state department has
already begun those conversations with
zinski to look at what that offramp
looks like um but yeah I'm not too sure
other than like explicitly stating
publicly like you can only fight until
this date I don't really know what what
else I would change I don't think I
don't think the Biden Administration
should have done that I I don't know
what else do you think Biden should cut
this deal on uh on the funding meaning
there's like there's this $15 billion
deal it's been held up by debate between
Republicans and Democrats over border
right so basically it contains $60
billion for ukraine4 billion for Israel
another several billion dollars for
taiwan's defense against China and then
includes some border funding and some
border Provisions Republicans want the
Border funding and the Border Provisions
because we can get into the illegal
immigration issue but that's a pretty
serious issue and Biden democ have been
unwilling to hold that up and that that
seems to me like just from put aside
Republican Democrat seems like political
malpractice meaning there's a widespread
perception in the United States that the
border is a disaster area Joe Biden
wants these things many Republicans
don't want these things if he caves On
the Border stuff he gets all the things
that he wants and he's going to be able
to go back to the moderates in the
country and say I did something about
the Border it seems like such an obvious
win if he caves On the Border stuff you
mean on the Ukraine stuff yes because
then he gets the whole package me he can
he can go back to his own base and he
can say listen guys I wanted to I wanted
to be easy on the border the Republicans
forced me to it but we needed the
Ukraine a we needed the Taiwan right
that's you're honestly you're going to
be more educated than me on this I don't
like uh or maybe maybe I just don't know
enough I don't like the principle that
when we negotiate things in the United
States there's like 50 million hostages
at all points in time for every single
thing like oh boy here comes the debt
ceiling what do the Republicans want
what do the Democrats want oh boy like
here you know we can't fund our
government um but I mean obviously the
the argument is going to be that if the
Ukraine funding doesn't come in this
bill and if Biden and his administration
feel like it's really important that un
unilaterally but as a single issue it's
not going to pass so um I would say that
at this point and I don't know what the
conversations look like between the B
Administration is zinsky I would say at
this point that it's probably fair to
start making contingencies on the money
that we give to Ukraine that listen like
this uh conflict has you know waged on
now like now we need to start looking
for potential peace we can't just write
you an unlimited check so I mean if
those strings are attached I'd be okay
with it but the broader question of like
is it okay to make this particular piece
of legislation with all this funding
contingent on uh the Ukrainian funding I
mean that just seems to be the way the
government works now
unfortunately